the steelers still have ben
roethlisberger on the roster he
met with reporters yesterday at an ota
session and he said a lot of interesting
things yeah let's begin with an exchange
on
his elbow surgery and what it may or may
not have done to the teams
passing the ball down the field in 2020
here's the exchange with ben
roethlisberger from tuesday
[Music]
ben historically you've been pretty good
throwing the deep ball over your career
last year not so much uh what was your
reason for that and
did it have anything to do with the
elbow at all in your opinion
well i was going to say mark you know i
had total reconstruction on my elbow it
might have something to do with it but
uh
no no excuses um you know it's my arm
feels great though
um i'll i'd like to wait to answer that
question until
we get into more this season and see how
it feels right now it feels really good
i mean you know my arm was was healed
obviously i played it was it was healthy
but
i think anybody that has a big surgery
um
it almost takes like like that year that
first year back is still
you're back but are you really back and
feeling great so that's why i i want to
reserve to answer that question until we
get into the seas a little bit to really
let you know how my arm feels even
compared to last year
chris i love it
when we articulate the excuse and then
say no excuses and he did it with kind
of a smile
yeah i think he's been around long
enough that he realizes
the cat's out of the bag by the time you
say no excuses
this is one of those where there's a
disconnect between what you read
and what you see and i think he knows
you know what you got me there
no excuses yeah right i had a total
reconstruction my elbow that's why i
didn't throw the ball down the field hey
no excuses
folks no excuses well the new men's
cologne
brought to you by ben rothersberger no
excuses i it just it just it was just it
was it was awkward
yeah it was self-aware there was no but
there was a self-awareness to it when he
smiled it's like you know you got me
here i'm stepping right into this yeah
now i understand why
reporters don't uh don't like that but
uh
hey look that had not been proffered by
anyone as an excuse last year for the
steelers not throwing the ball down the
field no
it was more that's just the way the
offense is under
randy feekner who is now not there for
reasons including they didn't get the
ball down the field nobody said hey this
guy's elbow
had a full reconstruction they just
weren't throwing the ball down the field
no exactly right and you know listen i
mean
i don't know is he is he saying there
that's where i'm like is he saying that
that affected it or
yes he didn't feel the same throwing the
ball deep down the field i mean that's i
guess that's what he's saying yeah but
like
i'm with you a little bit there mike in
that aspect you know
i saw plenty of deep balls early in the
year it didn't look like
it was an issue it did throughout the
year i mean i never looked at like
him throwing the ball and went oh man
he looks like he's got a popcorn a
popcorn you know arm
for for for an arm a popcorn gun arm
like that kind of thing no i
really didn't i thought i saw the
biggest drastic changes in his throwing
when
he kind of hurt his knee what was that
week four or five a little bit
that's when i thought i noticed a
difference but like you know we're
showing some throws here that are
aggressive down the field there's no
hitch in his giddy up there or anything
like that
you know i i so i'm i'm actually
surprised to hear him
i mean i don't know if that was an
excuse or he just got defensive all of a
sudden or what
but i certainly didn't see anything
physically that said oh he can't do that
or
oh he threw a 50-yard bomb to claypool
down the left sideline and i could tell
it hurt his arm or anything
i i couldn't tell that at the risk of
pointing out the egg all over your head
it's pop gun
pop gun that's what it is okay thank you
i knew i said something i could always
tell
by your face that i've said something
stupid i could tell you're just waiting
for me to finish my point so you can
correct me
i'm not aware of a popcorn gun yeah i
would not be
very afraid of a pop well that's that's
why it kind of makes sense
again on pop popcorn
then yes because that's essentially a
handful of bbs but if it's pop popcorn
bring it on
i'll i'll i'll stand down uh the barrel
of a popcorn gun okay
you mentioned the knee right you
mentioned the knee right and and i think
that's
far more significant than anything that
happened and maybe that's why you had
that little
smile when you talk about the elbow i
don't want to go to next level here but
the reality is
near the end of the season every week
someone was reporting
yeah the struggles that ben rothersburg
was having with his
knees not knee with his knees every week
steelers not listing him as having a
knee issue on the injury reporter they
got whacked in 2019
for not disclosing the elbow before the
elbow went during the week two game
against the seahawks and
you know they do the whole thing they
find the coach they find the
organization it's not a huge amount it's
basically a parking ticket but it's
still
a rare indication by the nfl that we got
some cheaters in here and
spoiler alert they got cheaters in there
not just in pittsburgh but everywhere
people look
as bill cower explained to ed bouchette
of the athletic recently
they're always looking for a way to get
an advantage and it's only cheating if
you get caught i don't know that
that's really the the right way to
phrase it but that's how cal
phrased it so yeah hey they they cheated
the injury report in 2019
and maybe he didn't mention his knees
because he doesn't want to go down that
path maybe
but the knees were an issue and he did
address
his late season struggles let's see if
he mentions the knees i haven't heard
this part of it here's roethlisberger
from yesterday
it didn't play well enough at the end of
the season it's it's no secret and i'll
be the first to
point the thumb up myself um you know
when the ball is in your hand every play
you have to make plays and you have to
play better football and um
you know that that's if the quarterback
myself is not playing good football
that almost especially late in the
season is directly related to winning
and losing
so um i'll take that play off and and
those games
on me is just feeling worn down not
playing good enough football at the end
of the season
feeling worn down worn down in what way
that's the thing the knees
you can't ignore what your eyes are
seeing and what your ears are hearing
what reporters are saying
they're concerned about his knees
they're concerned about his knees and
you see him hobbling and
you know that that's the thing that
concerns me about this experiment by the
steelers
they whipped themselves up into a state
of delusion that this guy's 29 not 39.
yeah sure he's 39
and a real third
yeah yeah yeah this is uh this is a 30
minute
rental car right this is this is a car
this is not a vehicle that has been
taken meticulous care of
right this is a car that has been beaten
into the ground and it's 39 years old
right and i just feel like they've it's
just like we're suspending disbelief
on that fact like guys he's still ben
roethlisberger he's a 39 year old ben
roethlisberger and there's a difference
there is a difference there's no doubt i
think i i still saw enough last year to
go
no you could win and you could do it
with them i will say that
now listen you're right i mean it's it's
you know it's a little crickety at times
and every now and then he needs a
tune-up and you know there's a wheel
wobbling and they got to do
that's why they got to change the way
they play it's not realistic
it's also why i'm not really buying like
the arm thing either
right like listen if your arm is really
hurting and i'm not
like challenging big ben here i'm really
not i'm kind of just challenging the
steelers in general and everything
here though but like if your arms hurt
you know you don't throw the ball 608
times and throw the ball 50 times every
game
they would have changed that you know to
me it was the offense was the issue
i don't think it's about like big ben
can't throw the ball down the field
i saw punny you know plenty of games
where he was aggressive
to me it was more maybe where he
affected the offenses like we talked
about last year changing a run play to a
short pass play and do
all that but either way we talked about
this a lot and i give them a lot of
credit for one
like taking the blame there right there
like you know say i didn't play good
enough
listen that's really nice of him to say
they didn't do crap diddly squat to help
him either at the end of the year i'll
say that for him no doubt about it
i mean come on you know short
predictable
pass plays like we talked about no run
game nothing there
to help him out that way so i really
appreciate him like taking one on the
chin there for the team and all of that
but they have to change the way they're
playing for the reasons you mentioned
you know so they're not so predictable
and like if you just look at his season
you know as it goes you can kind of see
the trend of teams caught on to what
they did
early in the year they were throwing it
more aggressively and getting more yards
and doing things like that
as the year went on we get into late in
the year mike i mean he's having games
where
it's 5.1 yards 4.5 yards per
per attempt and things like that you
know that just tells me a lack of
aggressiveness
lack of you know uh creativity in the
office to create big plays and you see
the numbers here
so you know big ben wasn't at his best i
know that but
you know leica brady and like to your
point you're talking about they gotta
help
him be healthy and be the best he can be
and not go
hey you're 39 and we're gonna ask you to
drop back
and with no run game throw the ball
and carry us you know every game like
you're a young guy and
then that's where i just don't think
it's realistic well look a simple
explanation
they had gotten away from the running
game yeah short passing game
became the running replacement right for
the running game
and after x number of games defenses
that study film
and game plan for their contests against
the steelers
saw what they were doing and they didn't
change it yeah you kept doing it yeah
the crew
the receivers got criticized for drops
as you said last year
it's hard to hold on to the football
when the safety is teeing off on the guy
who's coming across the middle because
they know it's going to be a short pass
right
and they've seen it on film 100 times
right so
and and you know i i appreciate that
you're crediting roethlisberger for
taking blame here but maybe he's taking
the blame because that's where the blame
resides well
i'm sure too much time changing the play
at the line of scrimmage
maybe he had no faith in the running
game yeah and and he just decided you
know i'm not going to hand it off to a
guy who's going to gain one or two yards
i'm going to try to get the ball down
the field a little bit and look
i guess we know the the arm still works
and the body still works because
he got over 500 passing yards in the
playoffs right that's what i mean
because he needed to yeah but chris
there's 17 regular season games i know
i just still i still believe that by the
time we get to november
one or both sides of this player and
team are going to regret that he came
back for one more year like
brett favre in 2010 i think they're
going to regret that they that they ran
it back one more time well
you know they might you're right they're
playing with fire there's no doubt about
that i mean
i won't deny that but i do think like
one of the goals for the year
for that team and especially again i'll
say it with their backup quarterback
situation which i have no faith in i'd
like to state that one more time
that one of the goals for the year and
something that should be on mike
tomlin's radar
is a little again i'm going to go back
to tampa it protect
brady brady brady brady brady protect
and protect him we want to make sure
he's okay healthy play off run next year
whatever it may be
it's got to be a little bit part of
their thought process when even game
planning
you know that's what that's what you got
to do when you have a quarterback of
this age and you want them to survive
through the year
and be healthy yeah you're going to have
to manage practice and reps and do all
things like that
but you're going to have to think about
you know oh okay
i like this play but man you know
it could leave him open with a lack of
protection here and they bring this one
extra guy
sometimes on this blitz and you know
let's just err on keeping the tight end
in and the running back in and make him
feel comfortable there you know so he
feels comfortable and then he doesn't
get hit it's
again a lot like what we saw from brady
and them last year they kind of just
said okay
we're forget trying to figure everything
out we're just going to make you feel
comfortable
and make it simple and just throw some
strikes for us and i think if they can
stay within that mold
then they got a fighting chance to to
not have regret like you're talking
about
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports